très longtemps lorsque je me présentais
dans les apéros dans les réseautage mon
titre chasseuse de tête provoquait
toujours des réactions très différentes
que ce soit de la curiosité de l'intérêt
ou même parfois de la gêne
je suis persuadée que vous avez déjà été
chassé ou quelqu'un de votre entourage
par un head Hunter un chasseur de tête
c'est souvent vrai et parfois un
fantasme je préfère personnellement
qu'on dise que je suis une chasseuse de
talents
j'ai créé ma société en 2010 un cabinet
de recrutement
alors me voici avec mon ordinateur sur
le bras dans les lobbies d'hôtel à
rencontrer des candidats et créer mon
réseau de super-héros
en parallèle je contactais des
entreprises pour leur proposer mes
services de recrutement personne ne me
connaissait la situation économique
était difficile et toutes ces
institutions avaient déjà leur liste de
cabinets de recrutement préféré
mais je continuais je les appelais
beaucoup prospection de jour en jour et
je leur promettais en gardant le sourire
que j'ai rappellerai dans un mois pour
tenter à nouveau ma chance après des
centaines de téléphones de prospection
des portes fermées on me donne
finalement cette chance un de mes
anciens collègues devenus manager dans
une banque me dit nous avons beaucoup de
peine à trouver en profil de
spécialistes si jamais tu trouves cette
perle j'irai jusqu'au ressources
humaines et je l'ai convaincrai de
collaborer avec toi
et devinez quoi
j'ai trouvé la super héroïne ma première
perle les planètes étaient alignées mon
contact a tenu parole il est allé aux
ressources humaines et il les a
convaincus de collaborer avec nous
très rapidement j'ai gagné la confiance
des ressources humaines et nous avons
d'abord recruté pour des postes
opérationnels puis pour des postes
toujours plus seniors et au bout de
quelques mois nous avons recruté 6
membres de comités de direction dont
trois femmes et j'en suis très fière
en parallèle mes appels de prospection
commençaient à payer nous avons d'abord
collaboré avec une banque une deuxième
et puis au bout de quelques années
pratiquement toutes les banques de la
place financière en Suisse
des lobbies d'hôtel j'ai pris un petit
bureau
engagé une collaboratrice puis mon mari
et d'autres collaborateurs et l'aventure
dure maintenant depuis plus de 13 ans
mais qu'est-ce qui fait qu'on est un
super héros vous allez me demander
pourquoi est-ce qu'une personne aura
plus de succès dans la vie
professionnelle qu'une autre
est-ce qu'il s'agit uniquement de
compétences techniques
je ne le pense pas il y a évidemment la
chance qui peut être un élément
important comme de se trouver au bon
moment au bon endroit mais je pense
qu'il est important de maîtriser les
éléments que l'on peut contrôler comme
son c'est compétences son attitude et
son expertise et dans les compétences il
y a des adjectifs ou des qualités qui
sont très importantes aussi et qu'on
retrouve beaucoup dans le dans le monde
du travail évidemment aujourd'hui
l'agilité au sens de la communication et
l'esprit d'équipe
et je suis sûr que vous super héros dans
la salle aujourd'hui vous vous
reconnaissez par rapport à ces qualités
j'en ajouterai deux la résilience et
l'authenticité
la résilience est une compétence aux
qualités qui me ressemble beaucoup et
qui ressemble beaucoup aux entrepreneurs
dans la salle aujourd'hui
on tombe on se relève on tombe à nouveau
et on continue le chemin et toujours
avec le sourire
finalement la résilience est une
compétence essentielle dans le monde du
travail aujourd'hui
laissez-moi vous parler l'histoire
vous racontez plutôt l'histoire d'un
super héros de la résilience que j'ai
rencontré il y a de nombreuses années
il s'appelle Paul Paul travaillait comme
gestionnaire de fortune dans une banque
internationale à Genève et il avait
travaillé pratiquement toute sa vie dans
cette banque il décide d'un jour de
changer d'établissement en pensant que
ça l'aiderait dans sa carrière et
malheureusement il fait le mauvais choix
ce qui peut arriver mais la crise
financière frappe et Paul se retrouve
sans emploi sans avenir sans perspective
et en plus dormant sur le canapé de son
ex petit ami
il avait évidemment le moral dans les
chaussettes et je le rencontre à ce
moment-là il me dit écoute je suis prêt
à faire n'importe quoi pour rebondir il
était en fin de chômage
en parallèle une de mes amis travaillant
dans les ressources humaines me dit
écoute j'ai besoin de quelqu'un c'est
peut-être pas ton domaine mais j'ai
besoin de quelqu'un de toute confiance
qui pourra faire de l'archivage dans
notre département des ressources
humaines et quelqu'un qui soit confident
enfin qui est notion de la
confidentialité est libre de suite alors
évidemment je pense à mon ami Paul et je
dis les beaucoup trop qualifié pour
faire de l'archivage mais fais-moi
confiance
elle le rencontre et langage Paul fait
de l'archivage pendant quelques mois
puis il réussit à créer son propre
réseau à l'intérieur de la banque et
rencontre les bonnes personnes au bon
moment
alors grâce à sa travail et son attitude
sa personnalité il décroche un poste
très intéressant
au-delà de ce qui pouvait attendre dans
son domaine d'expertise avec un salaire
qui était bien plus que ce qu'il avait
auparavant
cette histoire de Paul est empreinte
d'humilité et de résilience je suis sûr
que vous êtes d'accord elle montre aussi
que Paul a réussi à prendre cette
adversité et à développer quelque chose
de différent sa différence donc
finalement comme je l'ai dit la
résilience est une compétence clé dans
le monde du travail d'aujourd'hui où les
changements et les défis sont constants
et la capacité à s'adapter et à rebondir
et crucial
et même dans les moments les plus
difficiles les plus sombres cela nous
montre que nous sommes capables de
rebondir de de redessiner et de réussir
je vous ai parlé de la résilience
parlons maintenant de l'authenticité
qui parmi vous n'a jamais menti dans un
entretien d'embauche lever la main
ah je vois pas mal demande nous sommes à
Fribourg donc
bravo il paraît j'ai vu une étude qui
disait que 81 à 99% des gens avaient
admis avoir menti pendant un entretien
alors ça peut être un tout petit
mensonge comme omettre quelque chose
mentir sur son salaire ou exagérer des
choses donc le mensonge peut être très
très large
je pense que c'est important de se poser
la question s'il en est fait l'un pour
l'autre comme dans une relation
amoureuse vous avez envie de plaire et
vous allez montrer le meilleur de
vous-même mais finalement d'être
authentique va permettre de construire
une relation de confiance et pérenne
en 2019 fin 2018 début 2019 j'ai créé
une association qui s'appelle hiami and
fabulous parce que nous sommes tous
fabuleux engagez moi je suis fabuleux et
l'idée c'était de construire des ponts
entre les générations à la base et
d'avoir d'un côté les experts des
ressources humaines ou des managers ou
des entrepreneurs on a aussi des siéfo
qui sont venus et de l'autre des
personnes qui recherchaient du travail
et le but pour moi était de faire
rencontrer ces deux personnes et de
pouvoir avoir des conversations
authentiques parce que lorsque vous êtes
devant un une personne des Ressources
Humaines vous avez jamais vraiment
comment est-ce qu'elle va traiter votre
dossier les réponses ne viennent pas
forcément toujours donc l'idée est le
succès de ces événements réside dans le
fait que les experts répondent sans
langue de bois en toute authenticité à
toutes les questions que les
participants peuvent leur poser
après des centaines de rencontres et des
merveilleux résultats on a pu constater
que la chose qui fera la différence qui
fait la différence est-ce que les
ressources humaines demandent c'est
d'être authentique
dans ces événements nous avons aussi des
témoignages et c'est un de mes
témoignages qui m'a beaucoup marqué il
s'appelle Marie elle a 52 ans et Marie
s'est fait licencier d'un jour à l'autre
de son emploi mais Marie était une très
belle femme solide qui voilà elle avait
du courage et elle se dit je vais
chercher du travail alors elle a envoyé
plein de dossiers Marie mais recevait
aucune réponse et il lui manquait une
chose l'anglais
alors elle en parle à sa conseillère de
chômage et lui dit écoutez j'arrive en
fin de chômage je parle pas l'anglais il
faut absolument que je puisse avoir
l'anglais pour pouvoir travailler et
finalement la conseillère accepte sa
demande et l'envoie dans un petit
village paumé en Angleterre pour prendre
des cours d'anglais elle se retrouve
dans une classe avec des élèves et des
professeurs qui pourraient être ses
enfants et dans une famille en
demi-pension où elle doit s'adapter
aussi aux règles familiales elle en
prend un petit peu Marie pour par
rapport à sa personnalité c'est une
femme forte mais elle accepte de jouer
le jeu il revient gonflé à bloc avec son
diplôme en poche je la rencontre à ce
moment là et devinez quoi des planètes
sont toujours bien alignées nous avons
un poste pour elle mais tous les
entretiens se feront en anglais et grâce
à cette expérience Marie va pouvoir
décrocher un poste elle y est toujours
aujourd'hui
je parle de mouton rose on parle souvent
de moutons à 5 pattes en nous demande de
chercher des candidats qui n'existent
pas mais que veulent les super héros
qu'est-ce que vous voulez super-héros
très souvent on nous dit est-ce que
c'est plus de salaire non nous
constatons ou parfois peut-être mais
nous constatons que les super-héros ne
quittent pas leur emploi pour un
meilleur salaire il recherche avant tout
du sens de la reconnaissance et un
travail intéressant
et si des supers héros étaient dans vos
entreprises est-ce que les entreprises
s'intéressent réellement aux gens qui
sont aux employés au talent qui sont à
l'interne
certainement mais parfois c'est un petit
peu tard
et j'en ai fait l'expérience moi-même
c'est très difficile de voir un talent
partir on l'a engagé on l'a formé on l'a
on l'a choyé et puis finalement il
décide de quitter l'entreprise il décide
de quitter sa famille et là c'est très
très dur donc en tant qu'employeur j'ai
fait le choix de la question du
positionnement et je me suis dit que il
y avait certainement quelque chose à
faire
recruter un spécialiste très important
ça coûte de l'argent ça coûte du temps
c'est crucial pour une entreprise mais
savoir le garder aussi
alors retenir des talents c'est
finalement simple c'est beaucoup de bon
sens de l'humanité de la confiance
et voilà
j'ai oublié un mot c'est pas grave le
musée de ma vie oui donc lorsque
j'accompagne des des personnes dans leur
recherche de travail je propose un
exercice parfois
qui se résume en musée de la Vie donc je
leur demande de s'imaginer dans leur
musée un magnifique musée ou au mur se
ré-accrocher des photos ils se sont
sentis un jour super-héros super héroïne
et si aujourd'hui je fais l'exercice
avec vous devant vous et je pense à au
moment qui ont été importants pour ma
vie il y a évidemment
différents éléments qui me viennent en
tête
lorsque je vivais dans une caravane et
que je vendais des aspirateurs qui
fonctionnaient à l'eau
lorsque j'ai rencontré ma première
candidate j'avais 22 ans j'en faisais 17
elle en avait 50
évidemment toutes les toutes les
candidats tous les candidats que j'ai pu
aider qui étaient dans des situations
difficiles mon association hiami aime
fabulous parce que j'aligne ce que je
suis avec ce que je sais faire et d'un
point de vue plus personnel la naissance
de mes deux enfants je me suis sentie
super héroïne et finalement devant vous
on dépassant mes limites en sortant de
ma zone de confort je me sens super
héroïne alors je suis convaincue que
vous aussi dans différents moments vous
êtes vous avez ressenti ce côté
super-héros que ce soit quand vous avez
grimpé un arbre réussi des examens aider
un ami donner la vie finalement vous
avez donné le meilleur de vous-même sans
rien attendre en retour et ça je pense
que c'est l'essence d'être un super
héros
donc finalement être un super héros
n'est pas d'avoir une cape ou des
pouvoirs extraordinaires ça se résume
pas seulement à ça c'est aussi de
pouvoir mettre en oeuvre votre vos
compétences votre confiance votre
résilience votre humanité pour faire un
impact positif alors embrassant notre
super héros intérieur et efforçons-nous
d'être le changement que nous voulons
voir dans le monde
[Applaudissements]